Trascrizione: Sabrina Toscani
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Il deserto è difficile da definire,
perché, sicuramente, per me non è un luogo
forse è un non-luogo,
a dimostrazione del fatto
che si può essere in un deserto
anche in una sala gremita di persone.
Si può essere nel deserto
anche nel centro di New York,
quindi non è un luogo.
Nella mia visione,
il deserto è un'esperienza.
Come tutte le esperienze,
dipende esclusivamente da come
lo si vive, in negativo o in positivo,
io preferisco vivere tutto in positivo.
Stasera vorrei accompagnarvi
in un altro viaggio,
un viaggio attraverso i miei deserti,
un viaggio che parte
dal basso verso l'alto,
in un continuo.
Incominciamo subito.
Qui siamo molto in basso,
nelle caverne sotto la Sardegna.
A volte i deserti sono invisibili.
Noi siamo abituati a vederli all'esterno,
piatti, o con delle montagne.
Ma a volte i deserti sono interiori,
e non soltanto in senso morale,
il deserto che uno può avere dentro,
ma anche nel senso proprio fisico.
Qui siamo in un deserto
dentro una montagna,
svariati metri sotto le montagne.
In particolare, in questo momento,
in questa foto, sono in un budello
che mi schiaccia completamente
sotto decine e decine
di metri di terra, di roccia,
e tonnellate di roccia.
Mentre ero in questo budello,
ho pensato di spegnere la luce
che avevo sul casco,
ero completamente solo
dentro questo budello.
Che volevo sentire?
Volevo sentire il deserto
di questa montagna,
che mi schiacciava completamente.
Ed ero bloccato,
l'unico modo per spostarmi
in quel budello era in avanti,
spingendomi molto lentamente
con i piedi e con le mani.
Perché volevo provare la sensazione
di essere completamente solo.
Poi ho riacceso la luce,
ho rivisto i miei colleghi,
sono sbucato dall'altro lato,
quasi come fosse un premio,
c'era un fiume sotterraneo, meraviglioso.
In un deserto invisibile, sempre al buio,
trasformato da migliaia di anni
di lavoro sotterraneo nell'acqua.
In questa foto vediamo lo stesso deserto,
sempre sotto le montagne della Sardegna,
ma come vedete è cambiato completamente,
è completamente l'opposto.
Siamo passati da un budello
strettissimo a un deserto enorme.
Guardate le dimensioni, guardate
quest'uomo che sto indicando qui.
Questo è un uomo,
questa è una parete di circa 80 metri
di altezza, all'interno di una montagna,
quindi un mondo completamente sconosciuto,
di roccia, che racconta una storia.
Questa è la storia
di una pazienza infinita,
di movimenti impercettibili,
ma ineluttabili,
di acqua che, goccia dopo goccia,
trasforma la roccia
fino a dominarla,
perché quella parete
è completamente crollata,
creando questo deserto di pietre,
dove io sono con il mio equipaggio
della spedizione CAVES del 2014,
sottoterra, con un gruppo
di astronauti e di scienziati.
Perché?
Perché andiamo sottoterra?
Perché mandiamo gli astronauti sottoterra?
Bene, deserto non vuol dire
'mancanza di vita',
non vuol dire 'assenza di vita',
vuol dire tante cose,
ma non necessariamente quello.
Infatti, noi pensiamo che su Marte
ci siano delle grotte molto, molto grandi,
che proteggono l'habitat
sotterraneo dalle radiazioni.
Quindi pensiamo che sia un ottimo ambiente
per custodire ancora natura organica,
forse la vita, o comunque
i resti di quella vita.
Potrebbe essere uno dei primi luoghi
che visiteremo, quando andremo su Marte,
perché saremo protetti dalle radiazioni.
In questo deserto alle mie spalle
vedete un astronauta
che si accinge a calarsi
all'interno di una grotta
utilizzando gli stessi strumenti
che poi, un giorno,
gli astronauti del futuro
dovranno utilizzare per esplorare,
per fare esplorazioni
nelle caverne marziane,
o magari in un tubo lavico lunare.
Sappiamo che ci sono,
sappiamo che esistono.
Ma questo non è soltanto addestramento
per noi astronauti, è anche scienza.
Dovete sapere che nei deserti,
come in tutti gli ambienti estremi,
esistono procedure di evoluzione
in atto e perfettamente visibili.
In particolare, i deserti sotterranei
sono completamente privi di luce.
Se noi spegnessimo quella luce,
sarebbe assolutamente buio.
Un buio diverso da quello
che io ho provato nello spazio,
un buio più denso e carico
delle tonnellate di terra sopra di noi.
Bene, questi animaletti minuscoli
hanno abbandonato l'evoluzione normale
dei loro simili sopra la superficie,
per adattarsi a quelle condizioni
così estreme: pochissima energia,
niente luce.
Ecco che questi animali
diventano quasi trasparenti,
perché anche il colore, anche il generare
del colore è uno sforzo inutile,
e hanno abbandonato gli occhi,
sono animali senza occhi,
non hanno più questo organo,
e ne hanno sviluppati altri
che sono più utili sottoterra,
per sentire le vibrazioni,
per sentire la temperatura,
le variazioni minuscole,
e poter trovare un modo
di sostentare la propria vita.
Ecco che noi andiamo a cercare
sottoterra, con degli scienziati,
e impariamo anche
come fare il campionamento,
come raccoglierli,
in modo che, un giorno,
saremo in grado di farlo
anche su un altro pianeta.
Un gruppo molto famoso degli anni '70,
che mi piace moltissimo,
in una canzone ha scritto:
"L'oceano è un deserto
con la sua vita sotterranea,
costruita sommersa,
e il perfetto travestimento sopra".
E io l'ho visto.
Qui siamo a circa 20 m sotto il mare,
al largo della costa della Florida.
Tra l'altro è una spedizione
che si chiama NEEMO,
NASA Extreme Environment
Mission Operation.
La foto ha le caratteristiche
di una foto subacquea,
quindi non ha i colori brillanti,
però potete vedere
il deserto intorno a me.
È un vero deserto,
anche se è pieno di vita,
ma è deserto, con tutte le stesse
difficoltà di un ambiente estremo.
Abbiamo vissuto per circa due settimane
completamente in saturazione,
quindi non potevamo risalire,
in caso di emergenza,
a meno di avere un supporto speciale.
Tutto il necessario era con noi,
dovevamo portarlo appresso.
Ebbene, sott'acqua abbiamo fatto
la stessa sperimentazione
che faremmo su un altro corpo celeste,
ad esempio, lavorare in microgravità,
perché sott'acqua è possibile cambiare
il proprio assetto, per far finta,
per simulare di essere completamente
senza peso, o con un peso parziale.
Senza peso, come se fossimo
su un asteroide,
su Deimos, su Phobos, intorno a Marte.
Oppure in gravità parziale,
come sulla Luna o su Marte.
Bene, per imparare a muoversi
in questi ambienti così diversi dal nostro
utilizziamo l'ambiente sottomarino,
per comprendere anche che strumenti
dobbiamo sviluppare, creare, sperimentare,
prima di poterli utilizzare su Marte.
Ed ecco perché in questo finto lander,
che vedete alle mie spalle,
abbiamo agganciato un braccio robotico
sul quale spostarci, per non contaminare
il suolo lunare, marziano e così via.
Ma non facciamo solo sperimentazione,
anche qui facciamo scienza.
Vedete, insieme alla Florida
International University
abbiamo studiato un fenomeno
pochissimo conosciuto,
la migrazione dei coralli.
I coralli sono molto sensibili
alla temperatura.
Abbiamo studiato in che modo
si spostano verso acque più profonde
a causa del riscaldamento globale.
Qui il riscaldamento globale
è un fatto, è scienza,
non è più un argomento politico,
non è più una discussione politica.
E per fare in modo
che questo deserto vivente
non diventi una valle della morte
dobbiamo fare qualcosa, adesso.
E noi ci stiamo provando con la scienza.
Torniamo in superficie.
Siamo partiti da sottoterra
e andiamo più in alto,
passando per il mare,
torniamo in superficie.
Qui siamo a Lanzarote,
per un altro progetto di esplorazione
che si chiama Pangea,
come il macro-continente
che poi ha dato origine
a tutti i continenti.
Qui siamo su un cratere,
di cui possiamo raccontare la storia
solo se conosciamo
il linguaggio della Terra.
I geologi parlano
il linguaggio delle rocce,
sono in grado di ascoltarne la storia,
di sentirne il racconto,
e sono in grado di interpretarlo per noi.
Io non sono un geologo,
non posso interpretare
le conformazioni del terreno
quando mi guardo intorno,
ma utilizzando le loro informazioni,
le loro istruzioni,
posso descrivere come se fossero
i loro occhi ad osservarlo,
in modo che loro possano
invece raccontarne poi la storia
e farne scienza.
Perché comprendere
come si evolve un terreno
in milioni e milioni di anni,
ere che, rispetto alla vita umana,
hanno delle tempistiche incomprensibili,
comprendere in che modo
il terreno si è evoluto,
ci permette anche di capire
come si evolverà in futuro,
e di comprendere la storia dell'universo.
Io mi chiedo:
per trovare un posto sulla Terra
che assomiglia a Marte,
mi piacerebbe poter essere...
Quello sono io.
In quel momento pensavo proprio:
potrei essere su Marte,
ma non lo sono, sono sulla Terra.
E chissà che storia
raccontano questi sassi rossi,
questa valle completamente
diversa da qualsiasi altro ambiente.
Un ambiente che potrebbe essere su Marte.
Abbiamo provato con i nostri istruttori,
geologi, professionisti, esploratori,
a cercare di raccontare questa storia,
ma è una storia veramente complessa,
sarebbe bello un giorno
poterla raccontare.
Andiamo ancora più in alto.
Questo è il deserto
più estremo per eccellenza,
ed è l'unico deserto
a essere veramente vuoto.
Lo so che è vuoto,
perché lì sto per uscire
dalla Stazione Spaziale Internazionale,
una camera stagna, che abbiamo
depressurizzato completamente,
e lo scampanellio disordinato
degli strumenti che ho davanti
a un certo punto è scomparso,
è diventato silenzioso,
non c'era più suono.
Quindi, anche se sono dentro la stazione,
sono già nel deserto,
nel deserto del vuoto dello spazio.
Ho provato due sensazioni
che sono tipiche del deserto.
Sapete, nei deserti, per chi ha avuto
l'esperienza di poterli vivere,
gli spettacoli della natura
sono di una bellezza rara, diversa.
Vedere le stelle da un deserto
ha un'intensità superiore,
un tramonto, un'alba.
Bene, io ho visto un'alba dallo spazio
mentre ero agganciato al braccio spaziale,
al braccio robotico.
E l'alba dallo spazio
è un'esperienza diversa.
È un'esperienza estremamente rapida.
In pochissimi istanti, dal nero
che vi assorbe completamente,
che vi toglie qualsiasi
sensazione di colore,
da questo nero che vi assorbe
anche nel pensiero,
si passa all'esplosione di colori,
in un attimo.
Io volavo sopra l'Oceano Atlantico.
A un certo punto il blu dell'oceano
si è trasformato in azzurro,
poi nel bianco delle onde,
poi nella terracotta della costa africana,
nel verde e poi il blu del cielo.
Tutto in un attimo, è una sensazione
che toglie il fiato.
E mentre...
E così come il tramonto
è estremamente tragico nel deserto,
anch'io ho sperimentato
un tramonto diverso da tutti gli altri.
Ho sperimentato un tramonto
mentre ero isolato fuori dalla Stazione,
in emergenza, quando il mio casco
ha cominciato a riempirsi d'acqua
per ricordarmi
che la natura ha sempre
il modo di prendere il sopravvento
sul singolo individuo.
Lì, nell'ambiente più estremo
che esiste al mondo,
o fuori dal mondo,
senza atmosfera, senza aria,
con temperature
che vanno da -150° a +150°,
il mio scafandro,
che è il mio unico strumento
tecnologico che mi tiene in vita,
è andato in avaria,
riempiendomi il casco di acqua.
È un tipo di deserto diverso
che si viene a provare,
e quando è tramontato il sole
ho perso anche l'unico strumento
che con facilità
mi avrebbe riportato a casa:
gli occhi.
Infine, questa foto,
che adesso vedete alle mie spalle,
questa foto è dedicata
a chi in sala è più giovane,
alla prossima generazione.
È un invito, ma anche una sfida.
E in questa foto, la cosa più bella
che si riesce a vedere
è il riflesso della Terra.
E la mia sfida è di migliorare
questa foto,
di superarla,
perché l'uomo ha un gene,
che è quello dell'esplorazione,
è un vero e proprio gene,
il gene di Ulisse.
Quando noi osserviamo un orizzonte
abbiamo l'istinto di superarlo,
non possiamo fare a meno di chiederci
cosa c'è al di là di quell'orizzonte.
Io oggi lavoro
per permettere ai più giovani
di superare quell'orizzonte.
E la mia sfida è di fare questa foto,
nel futuro, un giorno,
con un deserto alle spalle.
Mi piacerebbe vedere questo pianeta
diventare tutto rosso
della sabbia di Marte.
Grazie dell'attenzione.
Buona serata.
(Applausi)